the aftermath of a Russian strike
victims are trying to recover from the
shock dozens of people were killed when
missiles hit the city of Chaplin in
eastern Ukraine
lost his 11 year old son in one of the
strikes in a residential area
yes he was in the house he was thrown
out of there we look for him here in the
ruins and he was lying here nobody knew
that he was here nobody knew we thought
maybe he was thrown onto the roof but he
was lying here
missiles also hit a passenger train
killing dozens of people including
children the Russian defense Ministry
says the attack killed more than 200
Ukrainian service members and destroyed
military equipment
people in their homes at the time say
the attacks came as a surprise
there was no sound nothing at all was
heard just an explosion fire explosion
and then the fire started
this is the second time Russia has hit a
passenger train during the war last
April more than 50 people were killed in
a railway station in gramatorsk also in
the east
the attacks in Chaplin happened on
Wednesday while Ukraine celebrated 31
years of independence from Soviet rule
the Russian government says it's trying
to prevent civilian casualties but the
reality on the ground is completely
different as schools hospitals and
universities have been shelled in the
past months and civilian deaths continue
to mount